yeah welcome to this video playing
anecdotal from the Netherlands right
yeah and it Dalton I'm not sure is there
an English word like anecdotes I don't
think so it means like smaller stories
from all times something like that ok
now let's I know it's boring but I have
quite good results with this opening no
not really why should that wrong I'm not
playing this to draw yeah rookie 5 this
look I'm d8 getting it back let's look
well I think I can take care of this is
the way this plate and then ya hear what
has got an extra Paul and we'll keep it
at least for a small while black cannot
get it back instantly with taking twice
because of up to eight and it's it's um
okay for black he's got compensation but
right on the other hand still can hope
to convert the poly the idea in an ideal
scenario would be to be able to play f4f
45 not sure that I will manage here but
I'll try FY will state yeah I will take
C 3 and e four so I play rook e1
intending f45 maybe maybe a g5 as a good
news now no I'm sorry honey to drink
something here okay playing them more or
less nothing news why not a form let's
see
yeah if I'm if he allows me to do that I
I will 94 would be nice next smooth yes
still naughty form or not
yeah it's it's the light f6 tactic which
she ignores and because this is
protected I'm such a such a [ __ ] d 7
yeah i can i can win e8 but this wasn't
the the idea yeah i can win the exchange
but this never was my intention because
this is this is some compensation for
for black with Bishop e3 coming this
should be three a droopy five then he
he's got the two had two bishops and an
active pollution would you blame it's
not easy
hmm how to to get some coordination into
this
these three is also week I wanted to go
to detune okay yeah this isn't exactly
difficult Bishop f5 okay yeah I can't
whatever donating a hotel Paul isn't
helping I hope the ADA I need to return
him Great King C to D to C 1 yeah of
course I'm I need to return that and I
had intended this anyway but not with
like losing two moves because of idiotic
mouth lips and whatever
yeah maybe maybe i can get III came
and yeah what Bishop takes what else and
you know I go look in one cookie tree
isn't just bad
shouldn't be too bad check
check
all right let's try 94 94 to f6 or d6
for some counterclaim
check
check
yeah this really was an idiotic game
what the heck did I do that now our King
situ was of course a completely complete
11 with the most slip type of thing I
didn't really want to play that this
position was difficult though it wasn't
wasn't like him I'm winning or anything
also I was complicated he has some
definite compensation further for the
poem time warning
check
check
check
yeah so useless anyway you have a king
see to what what crap it is so idiotic I
mean if you fail opponent place this you
know this really brain-dead or made a
mall slip going into Bishop f5 with the
check I wanted to play King detune in
order to to set back here but even this
is really okay for black Bishop f5 is
even winning for black Oh quite
remarkable not understand why really
Bishop f5 because probably of rock the
age group the 8th Red King be one is the
best news in order to go in the corner
Wow
night c24 is what I need to play what is
the difference I'm not see to you for
even wins I mean the compass only on 09
but it's probably I mean I would be
really amazed if this is good for black
but I don't really understand that yet
yes this jack I know I have before I've
before now haha ok before yeah okay this
is this is ok for what this is ok I'm
much better coordinated to him it's not
clear cut or winning or what but this is
much better than the game of course yeah
I thought it was really strange that he
allowed this this looks like yeah this
also looks great when I had
hallucinations anyway I thought I would
attack d 7 I didn't really see the bush
of the night on once he 5 that this is
actually good for black is a bit of a
coincidence I mean he never calculated
this I mean how that this is Bishop f5
group d 8 is actually great for black he
played orders instantly but ok blacks
collective pieces and sometimes works
that way yeah this is a core suicidal
check
Bishop f 2 is better okay but this is a
foursome just a bad position yeah this
is not defensible like it's winning
alright thanks for watching